hallo meine Lieben heute gibt es endlich
mal wieder Teigtaschen diesmal machen
wir Piroschki und zwar sind das
Teigtaschen die sind super schnell und
einfach zubereitet und man frittiert sie
statt sie in den Backofen zu schieben
die sind jetzt gefüllt mit einer richtig
leckeren kartoffelfüllung und ich zeige
euch jetzt ganz schnell wie das Ganze zu
Hause
[Musik]
funktioniert Teig besteht jetzt aus nur
fünf Zutaten und die ganz genauen
mengangaben schreibe ich euch wie immer
unten in der Infobox auf ich gebe jetzt
erst mal mein Mehl hier in die große
Rührschüssel und da VME ich mit den
sauberen Händen einfach eine kleine
Mulde ich habe hier die Milch in der
Mikrowelle erwärmt nicht zu heiß also am
besten nicht über 38 40° ist wirklich
nur lau war gebe ich jetzt in die Mulde
und da gebe ich die frische Hefe rein
ihr könnt auch Trockenhefe verwenden ich
schreibe euch wie gesagt alles noch mal
genau auf falls ihr frische Hefe gerade
nicht nicht da habt und zur frischen
Hefe gerne auch schon ein bisschen
Zucker mit dazu geben und dann nehme ich
mir jetzt einen Löffel und verrühre das
ganz grob miteinander und dann geht's
auch schon
[Musik]
weiter
das Salz gebe ich ganz zum Schluss mit
dazu und dann lasse ich das die Maschine
kneten bis ein homogener Teig entsteht
auf der Arbeitsfläche kann ich dann noch
mal gucken ob der Teig wirklich gut ist
und ihr merkt es daran dass der nicht
mehr an den Fingern klebt ihr könnt auch
Mini bisschen Mehl noch mit dazu geben
aber viel mehr Mehl braucht ihr
eigentlich gar nicht so das ganze jetzt
zu einer Kugelform und dann müssen wir
den Teig 60 Minuten gehen lassen an
einem warmen Ort möglichst ohne Durchzug
was ihr auch machen könnt ist den Ofen
auf 50° quasi Vorwärmen dann ausschalten
und dann kühlt er wieder ab auf ca 30°
und darin kann er dann schön gehen
dadurch dass sie alles offen ist habe
ich nämlich auch oft Durchzug so Teig
einmal hier reingeben ein bisschen
backtrenspray noch mal oben drüber und
dann richtig gut verschließen und dann
sehen wir uns gleich wieder wir machen
nämlich in der Zwischenzeit die leckere
kartoffelfüllung dafür werden Kartoffeln
geschält grob geschnitten und in
Salzwasser ca 20 Minuten lang komplett
durchgegart das Wasser habe ich jetzt
einmal weg geschüttet und das quasi
aufgefangen und das sind huch das sind
unsere Kartoffeln die wir gleich zur
Weiterverarbeitung benötigen jetzt habe
ich hier einmal schon vorbereitet
zwiebeln und Knoblauch also einfach nur
richtig schön fein hacken dann habe ich
hier meine Pfanne eigentlich ist das ein
recht schnelles Rezept das einzige sind
halt diese wtezeiten ich find es immer
cool dass man die Zwischenzeiten super
ausnutzen kann Olivenöl habe ich jetzt
hier meine Pfanne gegeben ich verlinke
euch meins auf jeden Fall in die Infobox
ich finde immer es macht so viel aus
welches Olivenöl man verwendet wenn das
wirklich nativ extra ist kalt gepresst
aus Erstpressung dann schmeckt man das
auch also man merkt wirklich den
Unterschied und jetzt einmal Knoblauch
und Zwiebeln ich hatte jetzt zufällig
schallotten da ihr könnt jegliche
Zwiebel nehmen die ihr da habt einmal
schön andünsten und dann zeige ich euch
gleich wie wir das ganze miteinander
[Musik]
vereinen so ich habe das jetzt ca 3
Minuten lang richtig schön glasig und
weich gedünstet jetzt gebe ich die
Kartoffeln einmal in eine größere Form
damit ich sie jetzt ganz einfach ein
wenig gröber zerstampfen kann und dann
kommt das einfach noch mit dazu das
ganze wird noch gesalzen und gepfeffert
und das war's und im Gegensatz zu jetzt
typisch türkischen porscher da kommt
jetzt kein Paprikamark Paprikapulver
oder oder oder mit hinzu da wird sehr
viel gesetzt auf den eigentlichen
Geschmack der Kartoffeln ich glaube
tatsächlich dass Knoblauch auch gar
nicht so typisch ist jetzt bei diesem
Rezept aber das das ist schon super
lecker also ihr könnt i natürlich auch
weglassen aber ich empfehle es euch auf
jeden Fall noch mit dazu Zug
[Musik]
geben so die kartoffelfüllung ist fertig
und der Teig ist in der Zwischenzeit
auch schön aufgegangen wir machen jetzt
daraus 12 Piroschki und daher nehme ich
mir jetzt mein Teig und ziehe den
einfach so ein bisschen in die Länge
weil dann kann ich mir die zwl Teile
besser einteilen so und zwar indem ich
einfach erstmal halbiere ich wieg das
jetzt auch nicht ab weil die werden ja
sowieso frittiert das ist jetzt nichts
was in den Ofen kommt und gleichzeitig
garen muss und wird deshalb immer die
gleiche Grammatur haben müssen nee wir
machen uns das jetzt hier ganz einfach
dann hier wieder in der Hälfte einmal
durchteilen und dann jedes teigteilchen
noch mal durch drei das kann ich jetzt
auch einfach schräg machen dann in
Kugeln oder zu Kugeln rollen besser
gesagt genau und anschließend wird noch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
befüllt ich habe die Teiglinge jetzt
noch mal unterm Tuch 10 Minuten ruhen
lassen denn wenn Sie entspannt sind dann
werden sie auch richtig schön fluffig
also macht das gerne man sieht auch dass
sie dann auch noch mal so ein bisschen
dicker geworden sind so und jetzt
einfach den Rest unterm Tuch lassen ich
habe jetzt hier einen kleinen Teil
meiner
Silikonmatte freigehalten damit ich hier
in aller Ruhe ausbreiten kann und zwar
mache ich das Oval ihr könnt das
entweder mit den Händen machen oder wozu
ich euch raten würde nehmt ein
ausrollstab weil dann habt ihr da ein
bisschen Druck drauf können das jetzt
auch es gibt ja auch wirklich manche
Rezepte soll man kein troller benutzen
oder kein ausrohstab dann soll man mit
den Händen arbeiten aber aber hier
dürfte das Rüchen den hole ich mir jetzt
mal ich habe die Abstandsringe jetzt
ganz abgemacht denn wir können das ruhig
relativ flach ausbreiten lasst euch da
auf jeden Fall gleich überall ein
bisschen Platz wenn ihr das befüllt ich
nehme jetzt erstmal ja wie viel nehme
ich denn so nach Gefühl sind das schon
so einhalb Esslöffel das lege ich mir
einfach nur in die Mitte und zuschließen
kann man jetzt die Teigtaschen indem man
hier einfach die zwei Enden in die Mitte
klappt und dann muss man da so ein
bisschen mit den Fingern kneifen und die
Spitzen werden dann noch ein bisschen so
nach innen geklappt es ist glaube ich
immer besser wenn man sieht als wenn ich
das jetzt erkläre aber so ist die Form
perfekt achte drauf dass sie wirklich
richtig zukneift weil das darf jetzt
beim Frittieren gleich nicht aufgehen
das ist ganz wichtig und das ist jetzt
die typische pedoschki Form und so mache
ich das jetzt weiter mit den restlichen
elf und dann wird
[Musik]
frittiert
ich habe mir jetzt eine hochrandpfanne
genommen und da frittiert Fett
reingegeben ihr merkt übrigens dann dass
das Fett fertig ist zum Frittieren wenn
auf einem schasschläg Spieß die Bläschen
relativ schnell hochsteigen wenn da gar
keine Bläschen dabei sind dann ist das
Fett noch zu kalt und wenn sie viel zu
schnell und brodelnd aufsteigen dann ist
es zu heiß und ihr müsst auch immer
wieder das sage ich auch in allen Videos
ihr müsst immer wieder auch mit der
Temperatur mal höher mal niedriger weil
ihr müsst euch vorstellen dass er jetzt
die Teigtaschen die sind ja jetzt nicht
heiß da trifft ja nicht heiß auf heiß
sondern kalt auf heiß und das kühlt das
Fett ja auch noch ab und jetzt könnt ihr
entweder ganz vorsichtig die Teigtaschen
hier so reinfallen lassen oder wenn ihr
euch unsicher seid nehmt ihr einfach ein
Stück Backpapier legt die drauf ihr
dürft S auch generell noch so ein
bisschen flach andrücken ganz vorsichtig
und dann könnt ihr das eben reingleiten
lassen das Backpapier an einer Ecke noch
festhalten und dann einfach wegziehen
wenn es sich von alleine
[Musik]
löst
was haben wir denn hier erzähl mal wir
erzäh mal für die Cam hab ich schon ich
erzäh für dich wir haben hier Piroschki
gefüllt mit Kartoffeln Piroschki
bedeutet eigentlich auf Albanisch du
bist doof ganz falsches Land was ist das
das ist ein russisches Rezept für mich
auch interessant weil aus der türkischen
Küche wir backen das immer nur im Ofen
die russ ich weiß es nicht ich glaub
schon lass mich geren jetzt ist da
drinne noch was drinne da drin ist noch
was drinne wie diese russischen Dinger
da
das si man merkt richtig diese knusprige
ich woll schon sagen au ist Kartoffel
ohne alles genau kartoffelfüllung ich
check jetzt ich weiß gar nicht jeder nim
eigenen ach ja genugig auf auf einmal
nicht aus einem Teller nehmen heute ist
alles anders ich stehe auch ich stand
stand ich jemals hier be
testestin ich habe mal was russes gessen
dieses diese Teig Teig Dinger noch mal
ich weiß nicht ich bin auf Wolke 7 es
schmeckt so heftig ich habe erstmal
gedacht ah das ist ja nur Salz und
Pfeffer bei den Kartoffeln aber
Knoblauch und Zwiebeln und Olivenöl da
kommt der Kartoffelgeschmack so gut
durch Leute und es ist so richtig knusig
gefährlich supere Leute schmeckt so gut
s Kartoffeln ja aber das schmeckt
sowieso sag prumkartoffel aber so
intensiv so richtig intensiv es ist halt
wirklich sch sehr lecker ge vor allem
was ich fei ist wirklich außen habt eine
ganz dünne kN ige Schicht dann kommt der
fluffige Teig und ich habe gar kein Ei
im im Teig unnötig nee nein aber das S
so herzhaften donutteig so ein bisschen
aber ich finde wirklich also der Teig
easy peasy oh ohne Ei und Easy Peasy
macht nach abonniert meinen Kanal
kostenlos um so ein genialen Content
nicht mehr zu verpassen und dann würde
ich mal sagen sehen wir uns beim
nächsten Mal tschüs C guck mal das ist
voll braun von außen und in ist so weiß
wie mein
Kopf